what [ __ ] worse can it be oh my god
Oh Alan sweet I want my shotgun down
wait
oh crap that's not chef cap it tells me
to go here but we just went there
it's a Dorito probably on okay flare ah
there's mean zombies I forget that every
night take two of these and call me in
two more
oh hey I don't want to give
oh [ __ ] oh it's a hug guy I don't wanna
hug him let's shoot him in [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you I don't shoot him you stupid
[ __ ] yeah bring me nice one just buy
something yeah [ __ ] shot
buckshot tuckshop
whoa whoa whoa [ __ ] wasting ammo ass
shot come on
getting annoying
go it is reloaded are you rap
shoot him in the [ __ ] no problem too
old
what he [ __ ] eats quick Jesus Christ
fish I could eat that quick
I mean why would ah it's just you and me
Rodriguez let's [ __ ] finish this
Jesus shop ah come on why do you shoot
the same time stupid [ __ ]
okay door okay headshot
ah what the balls
collateral collateral all that ah penis
where don't
good we're good it's no problem no
problem probably no more zombie there ah
my hamburger gets it for me it's cool
don't fall and hurt your button all
right I'll try not to
what the [ __ ]
it's off with that
bombuh okay so we're gonna go to the
rooftop and escape and I'll believe this
game is over
just sayin ah don't hug me
Jesus Christ you're ugly I rhymed I get
way too excited about small things move
where but I Pullip see epilepsy come on
thank you very cos you're a bro whoa
wait I got this boom headshot oh it's a
hug guy no [ __ ] hugs for him ah [ __ ]
I wish I'd been it's ways off
ah huh guy ah Jesus guys doesn't even
have a head how to [ __ ] their head shut
down go okay we got this Rodriguez
show them in the back I don't wanna
argue I really don't wanna again he's so
ugly
that's okay let's just kill him
talk shop
it's why the [ __ ]
I'm out of ammo but you're dead and oh
what the
I came good thank you Rodriguez let's
there you go
while taking this with me
oh we're alpha of course we're alfalfa's
oh man
I'm alpha I'm off
chareth over alpha oh there's the
shopper
ah
Oh what the balls everywhere
what the [ __ ] is going on okay so I
guess we're [ __ ] in a mental hospital
or whatever and my [ __ ] feet is cold
where's my slippers oh there they are
hmm yeah life is good
oh [ __ ] ever put the wrong one on the
rocks but god damn it I hate when that
happens
oh [ __ ] the game started
all right so that's how
I got all my weight it's not enough
Oh Rodriguez no both barrels
Oh who's that does that mean
your mind [ __ ] you have a lot of period
oh really oh let's see I remember him so
he's the bad guy but he was helping us
out though
wait
yes it was like gibran that actually
it's fine let's forget about him quick
all right
holy [ __ ] let's go down I mean up you
are on the floor I am
oh I remember this someone said I don't
remember though someone said it was
important than that I what are you gonna
do you have frickin spaz all right let's
go
no I mean say I don't was it goes thing
should I stay or should I go so come on
and let me now
I guess this thing kill him it's
otherwise it would be boring if I just
left right I hope it's the right choice
[ __ ] [ __ ]
says don't whisper to me oh [ __ ] ha ha
ha I was awesome that our wine what
mr. signed why am i doing so many have
noxious noises today about that okay
we're good
this isn't okay no one here evently
oh the [ __ ] is that
crane oh why why do I do things like
that stupid
um oh and health that you should means
boss battle oh who could just hit this
no problem no problem what the [ __ ] is
that
caution click no
sure to go down there whoa whoa
entire life beautiful as critical every
I illogical civilization in history of
the world is tried to control human by
oh really
after a few more
right now I can't
for example
ah ah [ __ ] I don't have a lot of ammo ah
penis there we go all this house when I
shout peanuts not always I guess but I
mean in real life it doesn't really work
now that I've tried
anyway
I like music
that I hope I wish I had a better gum
and a [ __ ] revolver oh [ __ ]
there we go problem no problemo
they're pretty confused aren't you this
to dazzle
yeah me too I just sitting there
what I supposed to souls in [ __ ]
postilion aren't I
click that I guess
whoa
one down
the pulse well what the
Paul's
oh you that ah then we have a real bro
you are a true bro
I had no option
[ __ ] I hate when they hump my face it's
not cool
they don't even have a
whoops
what's that doing anyway I thought it
was done holy [ __ ] there's more crap
that must miss something
no no I'm not no I'm not having [ __ ]
fun
what am I missing I don't have much time
either
come on what am i oh sweet
let's [ __ ] start
yeah
kick your ass of science that's not
corny
okay okay okay don't drop it in my face
bluie [ __ ] think of something Jesus
Christ what's that doing anyway
[ __ ] game
Oh what's going on here not sweet
that's pretty awesome
it means this can't go on forever live
only fake [ __ ] sold upon us all come
on
ah that was awesome okay that's
oh so what am I supposed to do shoot in
there [ __ ] hump there
it's a humping doesn't usually work
don't I think about it
what am I doing wrong what am i doing
right it's a [ __ ] down
I mean question or answer [ __ ] stop
jumping like it
Jesus Christ ah I have spots I've got
that helps blow it does nothing if if
the aisles are was putting whatever I
can't [ __ ] talk today
more [ __ ] stuff because I obviously I
can't solve this if anyone needs to use
sing beauty it's obvious I swear to
[ __ ] god where's my spaz Oh Ferris
[ __ ]
I can't
okay don't be mean don't be mean it's
not go and you're me what am I doing
wrong
half-hour Vegas
can I control I don't want more of this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you